This course will have five lessons.
In this first lesson we'll be giving you
an overview of what AB testing is and
what it can and can't be used for.
We'll also go over an example
AB test from start to finish so
that you can see what
the whole process looks like.
In that example we'll first choose
a metric for an experiment,
then review some necessary statistics.
Then we'll design our experiment and
finally we'll analyze the results.
Then each subsequent lesson of
the course will dive into more detail
on a particular part of the process.
In lesson two,
you'll be learning about how to protect
the participants of your experiment,
and what questions you should be
asking yourself regarding
the ethicality of experiments.
In lesson three will go into
more detail on choosing and
characterizing metrics to use
when evaluating your experiment.
In lesson four, we'll talk more about
designing your experiment, which
includes choosing which users go in your
control group and your experiment group.
And in lesson five we'll go over lots
of examples of what your results could
look like, how to analyze those results,
and how to draw valid conclusions.
Now you won't need any prior
experience with AB testing in order
to take this course, because we'll
be covering it from the ground up.
And you won't need any
programming experience either,
because this course won't cover how
to implement an AB testing framework.
It's about how to design and
analyze experiments.
Introductory knowledge of statistics,
on the other hand, will be required.
So if you need to brush up, check out
the links in the instructor's notes.
Now throughout the course I'll be
going over lots of examples and
giving you opportunities to
practice what you're learning.
I'll also be having
conversations with Diane and
Carrie about their
experience as an AB testing.
Let's do that now.